When did you start working as an EMT?
That was around the same time,
wasn't it?
Emt was about 12 summers ago for me.
I was turning 50 and I started going back to school for outdoor med response,
camping,
climbing and what,
what is it like when you go to one of those classes and they realize who you
are?
How weird is it kid?
Ah,
sometimes you can get a little bit uptight because I'm the oldest guy in the
room.
Okay.
Right.
And I want to clarify something.
Okay.
When I became an EMT shield number three,
two seven,
four 66 47th precinct,
big shout out to all of you who taught me and tolerated me until I became an EMT
and put on that uniform.
I wasn't somebody,
somebody cleaned the fucking truck up
until I put on that uniform.
Joe,
after training for how many months?
It's almost a year for me like this.
I wasn't someone,
someone clean up the track
and that was my job starting right off.
But,
uh,
I was also the somebody who dragged the oxygen box all 13 floors up in the
didn't walled projects should artists to artists.
How many times have you driven past something,
whether it's a huge building or a teepee,
I wonder what's in there.
Mm.
And then you go into them,
I wonder what's in the frigerator.
I wonder what they listened to in there and I wonder who the they are.
I have a fascination for that.
Mm.
My pop had a big sprawling I think.
Is it simply empathy for people?
You know,
when the fellows started getting age in the early eighties he started treating
him.
He's an eye surgeon and everybody,
my sisters and stuff started saying,
but this is a time when you think you can catch that shift from breathing it pop
and whatever.
And he turned to me,
I'll never forget,
he said,
I don't get to choose my patients.
Wow.
I don't get to choose my audience.
So what was the motivation to start doing that though?
We'll see what's in there.
Where is your rater Joe?
And you'll walk in first cause you're way stronger than me in case there's
trouble and you'll go and be on lunch and in case somebody comes at us,
you handle it.
Oh,
I had a,
I had a mentor named Kesha who had to pile or dread locks up so high that it was
as long as from her shoulders to the top of her head,
her haircut,
it was like she had cheered.
She put her hand up on top and Kesha walked in that door.
First Homie,
domestic disputes.
She dealt with the guys.
You had to be there for domestics as we.
Yeah.
Oh those are those.
Gary is a very,
and get an eye on your audience.
Stops being audience starts being the neighborhood and pretty soon you live in
the neighborhood.
I was under the train once in the Fulton Street station talking to a homeless
valid quick briefing.
Act like nothing's wrong.
See if I can get them to come out.
Hi,
you're hungry.
Train breathes.
Okay.
Subway obtained breeze.
It doesn't just sit there silently
and you got to go real.
Geez,
I'm laughing now,
but that's a nervous laugh.
And now every one of those folks is in my voice when I sing.
Whoo.
I liked that.
I liked that thought process.
When you decided to do this,
was this a conscience,
a conscious effort to try to just enrich your experiences?
Cross training,
cross training.
I'll give it to quick rationale and I also know it's going to change me.
Don't know how,
but she got to get in it.
And after a certain point in your life,
maybe a go where there is no shallow and challenge yourself as just as I move
somewhere.
That's a foreign language as you can't even read the street signs,
uh,
in Japan for example.
Um,
but you know,
you start off on the bunny slopes.
You don't serve 40 footers.
Righto.
At first you got to move to New York and go through that whole thing of what
have I done?
But what's the,
so what's the thought process when you like,
I'm going to be an EMT,
I'm going to study for a year.
I'm on a train,
I'm going to go out there and I'm gonna actually do it.
I okay.
Sometimes when I go for a walk in the city,
my plan is to just follow where the sun is beaming.
I get to an intersection,
the sun is on that far corner.
I'll cross over to that and then I'll look down the block and see where the sun
is and I walked down the block and get into that part and just do a lot of this
by yourself.
Oh yeah.
I did the same thing with EMT training.
Jeez.
My Dad was a doctor.
The first aid merit badge I got as a boy scout was first aid.
I was that guy and I learned that for skinny guy like me.
Real power probably came from being cool when everybody else is going.
Yeah.
Cause my dad had to do that.
I assisted him in surgeries at a very early age.
Oh yeah.
And you know and stuff that made everybody else I this pocket.
I have a good ambulance voice.
You want to hear it?
Let me do that.
Okay.
Hold on again.
You're going to be just fine.
Can you imagine,
you know,
being in an ambulance,
you look up and it's motherfucking David Lee Roth telling you you're going to be
okay.
He'd be like,
Oh,
I'm dead.
I must be dead.
I only twice has that actually happened cause I only worked in the hood.
I only worked around it at night.
I only worked,
she,
you know,
you would never expect to see me once was after Oz fest football stadium.
Yeah.
Unfortunate was uh,
you know,
uh,
drank too much or whatever and he was out of sorts and you know,
sitting in a corner,
somebody phoned him in from the local liquor store and you could see that
disbelief in his face,
you know,
and I leaned over and said to him,
Hey,
you're going to be just fine.
Like this is like the lyrics of an Ozzy song come to life,
you know?
But beyond that,
no,
nobody ever really did.
And uh,
you know,
Jesus,
I weighed 15 more pounds.
I was doing the Arnold routine at the wage stack because I was somebody,
well,
somebody help me lift this
my fourth day.
I'm not,
I'm them not a pretentious about what my fourth days work.
So you bulked up for the job?
Oh yeah.
And a,
I wait 15 more pounds and I lifted man,
I could lift.
I lifted people out of bathtubs.
I lifted him out of the ocean,
I lifted him out of the projects,
I lifted him out of the truck,
I lifted him into the other truck cause the first truck just broke down in the
snow.
I live
and uh,
just do this for all.
Sorry.
How long did you do this for?
I research did once about four and a half summers.
Four and a half years.
Okay.
And I,
you know,
in between,
uh,
playing and whatever,
and again,
a big shout out to all my teachers and mentors,
not a day goes by.
I don't think about it.
And not a day goes by that,
uh,
I don't use some skill including that,
you know,
that'll level your head a little bit.
Yeah.
Somebody go make some coffee,
Joel.
So you feel like for a guy like you who was such a gigantic superstar and you
just touring these huge arenas and people were freaking out every time they see
you,
for you,
it was,
um,
maybe a good way to balance things out too,
because you're seeing people in a life or death situation and dire straits when
they're unhealthy and they need help and you're out there in the down and dirty
and the nitty gritty,
like,
you know,
like you said,
trucks breaking down,
picking people up out of the bathtubs.
Well,
a lot of what you just described is the first response team.
Yes.
We always describe our patients,
our friends and clients.
Okay.
But the struggle for our,
I'll call it the uniform,
starts with military police,
fire first response I'll throw in nursing or emergency room,
and those of us with bells and whistles,
who she called the ambulance and et Cetera.
You see that from the inside out.
Yeah.
And that really will sharpen your vision.